hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well the portion of part three of a Manu
cons proliga to any future metaphysics
which is devoted to the cosmological
ideas is one of the longer sections
within that part of the work and it's
also one that's drawn a lot of attention
from people who are critics of K
Advocates of K going further in this
direction in terms of dialectic and
antinomies so it it's actually a very
important section and we'll have to look
at it broken down into parts now we
should notice from the very beginning
that the cosmological ideas are plural
but they do fall under one sort of very
very general rubric and he begins this
section by talking about that he tells
us I term this idea and there he uses it
singularly
cosmological because it always takes its
object object in this case from the
sensible world and it does not need any
other world than that whose object is
given to sense and it's quite
interesting
there Kant will actually use two
different words for object object and
gagan in that very last Clause of the
sentence the object is the object right
the gagin is the object
for um the the sense and so he says it
remains in this respect in its native
home and it doesn't become Transcendent
now if it's not becoming
Transcendent then we don't really need
to worry about it do we because we're
only concerned with these
transcendental ideas because they do in
fact go beyond the boundaries of
experience and get us into all sorts of
hot water seeking after Pina or things
in them cells right and K is going to
say yeah that's actually what's going to
happen in in the next sentence right so
he says the cosmological idea extends
yite it extends is a good translation
there goes further right it extends the
connection the the
interconnection of the
conditioned with its Miss right what are
we talking about there uh you know it's
tempting to say that this has to do
strictly just with causality and what
we're going to see is that cause is
going to get brought up into different
ways here but it's really a broader idea
of something conditioning something as
you know the
conditioner of something else which is
thereby condition shunned it is uh
determined it is brought to be in a
certain way and so he says that it
extends Beyond experience by looking at
this
relationship of uh the you know
condition with its condition whether
mathematical or dynamical so far that
experience can never keep up with it so
we inevitably take it beyond the
limitation
the boundaries of experience and so he
says it's therefore with regard to this
point always an idea whose object can
never be adequately given in any
experience and he's already given an
example of this with the psychological
ideas now he's going to talk about this
in terms of for example the entire
universe which we can't have an
experience of right because we cannot
take in the
totality of the world right and so you
know he's going to say um when it comes
to each of what we're going to call the
antinomies of pure reason we're going
inevitably Beyond experience into
something else and this is going to
raise some issues now he also tells us
interestingly in the first place the use
of a system of categories becomes here
so obvious and unmistakable that even if
there were not several other proofs of
it this alone would sufficiently prove
it indispensable in the system of pure
reason this is what leads him to talk
about there being four
kinds of um dialectical assertions right
and in each of these though he says
these refer to the absolute completeness
right and this is something that we've
talked about quite a bit as we've moved
through this
full right being brought to fruition
being brought to Perfection so the
completeness of what a series AA of
conditions for a given
condition each of these is referring not
just to one single relation but perhaps
an entire series uh of things which are
causes and effects you could say or
conditioned conditioning conditioned and
each in turn right so he tells us that
in Conformity with these cosmological
ideas there's only four kinds of
dialectical assertions of pure reason
and dialectical here sometimes people
think that dialectic is a good thing and
you know it is for some somebody like
Hegel or marks who are coming later
dialectical as opposed to
non-dialectical for Kant
dialectical always signals that there's
some sort of Illusion going on some sort
of falsity some sort of getting things
wrong or falling into a place that we
don't want to be so he tells us that
because these are dialectical they prove
that to each of them unequally specious
notice the term there specious
principles of pure reason a contradict
assertion stands opposed and so this is
this is going to be a big problem and so
for each of these and there's four of
them right we have a thesis or aat in
German and then we have an antithesis a
gagan literally it's
contradictory so you
know sentence counter sentence you could
also translate it that way and he tells
us that this antinomy now what is an
antinomy an antinomy is where both of
these can be given some sort of
reasonable grounding or justification
but they both can't be true at the same
time as a matter of fact could be
possible that both are false at the same
time as we're going to see and so you
got to ask what the hell's going on here
right what is happening with reason as
it is trying to go beyond the boundaries
of experience and figure things out
about stuff that really matters to us so
he tells us that this is not arbitrarily
invented but founded in the nature of
human reason so we're going to look at
that connection in just a bit but first
let's talk about what these four are so
he talks about uh mathematical and
dynamical and so we can associate them
into groups of two the first two are
mathematical so you know the the world
everything in the world right uh that's
mathematical quantitative and the others
are dynamical having to do with uh
causality itself so what is the first
one the world has as to time and space a
beginning or limit right in parentheses
Gren and beginning on fun so it's not
saying just the world per se the world
in relation to time and space which is
how we perceive the world it has some
sort of beginning in time or a limit to
the extent of the
world now you can argue that and we'll
look at how he does that in a in a
little bit but we can also say the world
is as to time and space infinite
so this is really containing two
different connected things uh it doesn't
have a beginning which means that the
world would be Eternal
right but it also means that the world
wouldn't have a end point it would be
infinite in space as well and we can
argue for both of these so which one's
right well that's a problem for Pure
reason isn't it let's look at the second
one similarly dealing with the world
everything in the world is
constituted out of the simple so there's
some sort of simple basis that we could
get to you know for a long time people
thought that was atoms uh the very word
atom means unable to be divided further
right at in in Greek and then you know
we said oh subatomic particles atoms are
actually these really cool things things
that we had in you know chemistry class
with electrons whizzing around the
outside in a nucleus of protons and
neutrons and then we're like all right
we hit bottom nope there's quarks right
and so we can keep going down further
and further and further but you know
this one is asserting there's going to
be some Bedrock that you're going to hit
sooner or later and we're going to be
able to say aha we have reached the
simple now you're going to have to have
a lot of simples in order to make that
work to that we can oppose this
antithesis there is nothing simple but
everything is composite there is no
bottom level no Bedrock that you can
ever reach everything can be broken down
even further so these are the
mathematical antinomies we can say
thesis and antitheses associated with
them then we get two others which uh K
calls
dynamical there are in the world causes
through
Freedom now that takes a little bit of
unpacking what's he talking about there
the issue of what we often term Free
Will can we actually be causes of our
own actions through our own Freedom or
are we always conditioned are we in a
certain respect self moove movers to use
an earlier terminology going all the way
back to Aristotle and Plato or are we
always conditioned right by what has
come before what is within us what is
driving us so Kant is not uh framing
this in terms of human beings or the
will but he's talking about causality
are there
causes that work
freely or is there no Freedom whatsoever
but all is nature now you can say well
wait a second why would nature be unfree
human nature after all shouldn't that be
free well you know remember that for
Kant what nature means is a whole system
of appearances that are governed by
laws so if all is nature nature that
means that everything is conditioned by
causes and there is no Freedom
whatsoever and you can argue either side
of this plausibly so we've got a problem
there right then finally we get to the
last antinomy in the series of world
causes there is some
necessary being and this is often you
know uh part of arguments for the
existence of God you you could think for
example of Thomas aquinus is Third Way
um so in the series of world causes
everything is connected cause and effect
there is some necessary being and
that'll be at the start of all of this
the necessary means it has to be the way
that it is it must exist right so that's
one possibility but we could also say
there is nothing necessary in the world
but in this
series all is contingent everything
could be different than it is including
the stuff that came before
causally you know uh there's no
absolutely necessary being so with each
of these thesis zots and antithesis
gagan zots and Kant is going to tell us
something very interesting about this
before he starts going into detail he
says and this is in
52a here is the most singular phenomenon
of human reason no other instance of
which can be shown in in its any other
use if as is commonly done we represent
to ourselves the appearances of the
sensible world as things in themselves
which you know K has said we can't do
that or we shouldn't do that then um we
assume the principles of their
combination as principle universally
valid of things in themselves not merely
of experience we are going to have an
unexpected conflict which can never be
removed in the common dogmatic way why
because the
thesis as well as the antithesis can be
shown by equally clear evident and
irresistible proofs so this goes beyond
just you know both of these are possible
both of these are probable both both of
these make sense he's saying you can
actually prove both sides of the
antithesis and not just with any old
proofs equally clear evident and
irresistible proofs so this is a problem
right so reason he says is divided
against itself and Skeptics love this as
he says it actually gives them Joy right
uh but the critical philosopher can't be
all that happy with this and so he goes
on and he says how do we wind up in
these problems he says we we can blunder
in various ways in metaphysics without
any fear of being detected in falsehood
why because we can never be refuted by
experience if we just avoid
self-contradiction well none of these
can be refuted by experience right you
can't look at the world and figure out
whether it has a beginning or whether
it's Eternal you can't look at the world
and our experience of it and figure out
whether there are basic building blocks
that are completely simple or whether
everything is composite you can't look
at the world or even at ourselves and
say that yes there are definitely or
there are definitely not causes through
Freedom nor can you have any sort of
experience which is going to give you
the existence or the non-existence of a
necessary being
so experience isn't going to help us we
have to look at the possibility of
contradiction and so he says the only
possible way in which reason could have
revealed unintentionally its secret
dialectic would be when it were made to
ground an assertion on an universally
admitted principle and deduce the exact
contrary with the greatest accuracy of
inference from another which is equally
granted and he says that's actually the
case here with regard to foreign natural
ideas of Reason four assertions on the
one side as many counter assertions on
the other side each consistantly
following from universally acknowledged
principles so what does this reveal to
us well this dialectical illusion of
pure reason as he calls it and then
there's a footnote where he says
something really quite interesting here
he says nature itself
seems to have established it the
antinomy of pure reason the fact that we
can argue plausibly actually uh
conclusively for each of these
sides um nature seems to have
established it with a view to stagger
reason in its daring pretentions and
force it to
self-examination for every proof which I
have given both of the thesis and
antithesis I pledge myself to be
responsible and thereby to show the
certainty of the inevitable
antinomy of reason and so this will lead
us to ex investigate the ultimate
Foundation of all the cognition of pure
reason with me more thoroughly as he did
in the critique of pure
reason what he's suggesting here without
providing any proof just saying ah this
is an interesting idea is that the fact
that we can actually come up with these
antinomies uh we can discover there is a
dialectic of pure reason shows that
something in nature something in the way
things are constituted wants us to use
our reason as a critical faculty does
Kant provide any proof for this no it's
a mere suggestion but a very interesting
one is it not so this is the beginning
of setting out the cosmological ideas in
that section of the
proma